we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p and we will
also have a voicemail today about louis
let's take a listen
hi david i was a twenty year hugest
stands who i've been watching you all
your your cancer face all these years
that right now i don't like you anymore
and my focus is only on your him some
co-worker lewis who never got any
attention all these years except to you
hear from lewis yeah this is someone who
would regularly leave voicemails about
my physical appearance and it's true
this individual completely neglected you
for years and now finally you are
getting the credit that they believe you
deserve and for that i guess we can all
be proud and happy yes thank you thank
you that's all I could say I'm flattered
on the bonus show today we will talk
about Olympic hormones suppression we
will talk about a Texas appeals court
halting an execution usually anytime
courts get involved in Texas with
executions they're expediting them not
not delaying them in any way and we will
also talk about how destroying history
can now be considered a war crime all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show david pakman.com slash membership
is the one way that you can sign up for
membership and get instant access to the
bonus show and i will remind you that
there is a coupon code currently still
available for people who want a
discounted membership that coupon code
is hey tree at 40 all one-word
h80 are IOT for zero use the coupon code
when you sign up get discounted instant
access to the world-famous bonus show